[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders well thank you for having me
mate
ah this is so great so you're calling
from berlin i am calling from berlin
that's correct yep
berlin berlin but you're actually you
love traveling around the world
bali all over the place right so i was
i look at the country i see the value
proposition the value for position is
what you get divided by the price so for
example
new york you get a 10 but you pay a 10.
tel aviv you get a 10 you pay a 10.
berlin you pay a four you get an 8.
bali which is another favorite place of
mine to live it's
you know you pay out three and you get a
nine so
okay when did this all start when
because you know you're you're in
finance you were in wall street you know
fordham columbia how did you go find
yourself involved so
we're so we're let's i'll cut the
boring part of my education and stuff
like that but you know after my studies
i went to
work in wall street and then my career
took me to australia to israel to south
america
for tax purposes and then
and then eventually what happened is
that around 2015 i was cast into
the survivor in israel which was
conducted
in honduras
which was a very good experience and i'm
sure
you know you're going to have a few
questions about that and after that i
started living around the world
quite like kind of like changing with
seasons and
um etc was that the turning point for
you
when you went to honduras and you found
a different way of living
was that the experience that really
changed your mindset
uh well i think if something's that
survivor
thought means that you cannot beat the
system if the system is against you
you know but but you know
i was i always thought it was very
boring to kind of like live in one place
regardless of how interesting your job
is and
for me as a person that gets bored very
fast i found it fascinating that you
know in this new age especially
if you work in a job that allows you to
work remotely you can just
switch places and meet new cultures and
the funny thing is like it's a small
conversation that we had before is
that you don't have to be rich to live
around the world but you do have to be
rich
to live in new york i meet a lot of my
friends that are making very big
salaries at google and other companies
and they're like
how do you travel the world you're rich
and i go you guys probably make more
money than me and you guys are stuck in
new york because you're just starting
that rat race
yeah so and you know that also alludes
to your sort of idea behind
living with minimalism which is also
very contrarian to
the wall street type of 100
you know this is a very good interesting
thing that you just said because the
first time i moved to live
abroad i had around 40 kilos of stuff
with me and
then the second when after that when i
moved to the next place i was thinking
like okay
i look at all my closet i'm like i
didn't wear 80
of it maybe i worked once or twice but
in the last six months when i was living
in panama i was like
maybe i wore like 20 or 30 of my
wardrobe so i said okay so i'm going to
get rid of most of this stuff that i
don't need so i just donated it
and then i moved on and then after i
moved to my my next location i figured
out like
from the 20 let's say from the hundred
percent that they had
left i would say like even from this i
don't need another 30
and then you figure out that you know
with like 15 kilos you can travel the
world and you have all you need
so and so you're living on 15 kilos of
of belongings
50 kilos belongs every time i buy
something i have a rule that every time
i buy something
i have to give out something wow so like
that you know like you know like you
only buy
something if you don't need something
else rather than hoarding stuff
okay omar minimalism and there's nothing
more minimal than going to an
island and and trying to survive with
the other
cast members in the very popular show
survivor which i'm also a very very big
big fan of and actually i believe i even
wrote you a note
you know back on this back when the show
aired three years ago
we were supposed to meet but we didn't
have time man you're too busy conquering
the world
it was years ago and you know you're you
exemplify
you know the more seasons that i watch
it's very clear that they have very
you know typecasts for the type of
people they're looking for in different
segments and you're very clearly this
the mastermind
of that season and coming in with a very
strategic approach talk to me a little
bit about this experience as a whole
and how you approached this incredible
game
so i came to this a lot of people came
to
especially our season was a celebrity
season so we had
different kind of people there that my
misunderstanding was i had a game plan
that involves strategy
normally in a normal survivor if my team
has five people and your team has four
people
all the four people of your team is
going home because how survival works is
you have it goes on a vote basis so if
one side has five the other one is four
they're done and that's what usually
happens in the american survivor and
before you throw all of them away you
start making new kind of like
relationships the problem with a
celebrity season is
and i'm gonna quote charlie munger i
think you're familiar with that name now
charlie monger the
psychic of warren buffett and he says
show me the incentive i'll tell you the
result
yeah and i had what i didn't take into
account is that we had some celebrities
that were paid a lot of money
and there was no chance that the
production is going to let them go home
interesting interesting so it was a bit
disappointing because
you know from one point of view i said
like you know you come with a strategy
you're a lot smarter than everybody else
but everybody's like a model an
actor or a taxi driver no insulting
anybody but you know still
and but but the funny thing is that
you're eventually playing this game
against the production who has
and the production goal is to get the
highest rating possible
yeah you know i think it's it's very
it's very interesting and i'm sure you
know
the way that you experience it on the
island and with all the emotions that go
there and all the
and you know you the things we see for
an hour a week
they they try to you know scram down
seven days worth of strategizing and
talking and then
we see the bits and pieces which are
alluding to this thriller-like moment of
the backstabbing
and and and and voting somebody out what
happens from the moment that you
find out you're gonna go on this game
how much research do you do how many
shows do you see
do you have a very clear game plan going
in there yeah
so what i did so first of all i was
really surprised because actually the
process to get into the show i think in
our case we had around
sixty thousand people that tried to get
on yeah fifty thousand
sixty thousand they say eighty thousand
but i think it was like sixty thousand
and and you know like the process itself
is a process of around six months
because you know you have to just you
know like
kind of going from 60 000 to 2000 which
is like people that you really think
it's around like a two-month process
wow and after that you have to see a
psychologist you have to do like raw
shark tests
you have to do in personal interviews
that last 10 hours
so it's a really long process and when
and you know even when you do the
vaccines
they tell you look there's still like
three people that are fighting for the
same role
we're gonna only let you know two weeks
before two weeks before
so only two weeks before you know for a
hundred percent that you're in
oh my god and from that moment on is
that just like cramming as much
strategy as you can 100 100 so what i
did is and that was my mistake is
i kind of went over the american name
shows to see who was the best player
ever and then i started to look how he
strategized you know what do you do do
you go and you still
you show yourself as a strategic person
do you hide it do you play the idiot
or do you go with this one so i had a
pretty clear strategy of
how how i'm doing things but the problem
is once you get to the island
you know like life all strategies go to
the garbage
a hundred percent no i remember i know i
was i remember
from i was thinking from six or seven
years old when i started watching
survivor i was just so
i i just i fell in love with this
concept of
you can strategize as much as you want
but then it's a people's game and not
only is it a people's game but in the
american show
at the end they vote after seeing the
show so they see that
yeah and so and that just you know so
and you know
there was one of the players russell who
notoriously came in second
place i think three times uh throughout
the american show
and i kept thinking like wow is he and
he says he's the best player in history
of survivor
and but at the same time he came in
second three times
so what is he really the best player i
don't know so omar
give me maybe like one or two you know
earned secrets from this experience that
you know
most people in the world will never have
because you went through this what are
some of the
really interesting things that you found
out maybe about yourself or about
survivor as a whole well i just say as
for survivor as a whole you know and
you have to take into account that if
production wants to protect someone he's
going to be protected right
even if god wants to throw him away from
the show and production does not want to
throw him from the show you're not going
to be able to do that
which kind of flame is the thing for
example in our show we had a few
celebrities
and how it works is let's say um i want
to throw you you're a celebrity and i
want to throw you off the show
okay so they're going to do a
competition let's say both of us have to
find
one key that opens the box and we both
have tools yes
and we both have kind of like a box with
keys
and it goes on speed you know the first
one that finds the right key
opens the box but you what you're not
going to know back home is
that you know in one person case the one
that want to keep you know 90
of the keys can open the box and the
other one only one
okay so you know once you edit
everything it's kind of like was pretty
disappointing the fact that you know the
production controls everything in other
players
right no i'm sure that i'm sure that's
very difficult did you find out
something about yourself
while being on the island and you know
for a lot of people it was very hard for
me as someone to practice meditation and
calmness and
i you know doing ayahuasca before that
quite a few times
teaches you a lot of things about life
and one of this that what is that
ayahuasca what is that i i think your
viewers are not going to know better
than you what ayahuasca is and i think
you could
you need to take a look at it ayahuasca
is like the strongest and
dmt kind of like drink that you can get
it only exists in the amazon forest
and kind of takes you to an alternative
consciousness
yeah that definitely important kind of
kind of changes your view on reality but
in a good way
like not in a crazy way so
you know i think a person that takes
life not very seriously is not going to
be affected by all this
drama mind games for me it was just an
adventure you know that i went to enjoy
but
yeah you know i was surprised because i
was a lot of times i was
starved and stuff like that and then my
mind started falling
apart but you know i still picked it
back but yeah
i think when you're starved and when
there's a lot of drama going around you
even if you're a calm person
you start acting out of character and i
was surprised that even me at some point
you kind of like
lost it you know i think i i've it's
been a dream of mine to to someday be on
either the israeli or the or the
american one
mainly also to test myself and see am i
going to be able to keep my composure
and you know my strategy
thinking during those difficult times so
now
survivor is over and and life takes you
on a different path from wall street
right so
what do you do now so what happens is um
i met this
big investor and i used to go i went to
work
with him a little bit and he was one of
the biggest israeli value investors
and together we found this instrument in
finance
that is probably the best kept secret at
the time that nobody has ever heard
about it's called the vxx
and what happens is this instrument is
flawed
and after that you know after we
discovered it three four years later a
lot of hedge funds found this stuff
but you know this this thing like over
the long run there's no better assets in
the stock market to go short because
it constantly makes you money so we
started focusing on this
and you know i made a nice amount of
money and
it's a shorting mechanism it's an it's a
mathematical instrument
okay because of how it's mathematically
built it always loses money eventually
in the long run in the shortcut
in the short run you can lose your pants
this is why you need to know how to
manage it but overall
from 2009 it made better returns than
bitcoin shorting this thing just so you
can understand
how big how good this this this thing
can still make you a lot of money
it's it's like um i don't know how it
exists but it does
so we focused on this you know we made
kind of a good amount of money i made a
good amount of money and
during that time you know like i started
kind of focusing on contrary and
investing
and i also realized that i achieved
the amount of money that i want to have
to make me happy but my surroundings
kept telling me no no no no why you
don't want a villa
you don't want the porsche are you
stupid like why don't we do this like
come on come raise money i had a couple
of hedge funds in the states that you
know approached me hey let's do this
let's do that
and you know i i almost got convinced to
join that
but you know eventually like i figured
out that that's not what
makes me happy yeah so i kind of said
look you know i think the purpose in
life is
to have the amount of money that you're
comfortable not that you're rich
you know well i think i mean i i love
that i love that mindset but it just
sounds so weird to me that you're coming
from this finance background which is
all about how do i
optimize my my intake wall street
the persona and yet you're here telling
me i'm fine with
minimalism and things that just let me
live comfortably
a hundred percent okay and you ask a
very good question i think the thing is
if i still lived in new york and did not
leave new york
i would not be able to change my mindset
because you are the product of your
surrounding you know if you see
everybody
hey bro i'm the cool you know i have
this new model i have this new car i
have
you also want it because you're part of
it and you know the entire thing that
goes into your brain all the time is
more more and more only when you go
outside
you know the circus you can see it in
like a
neutral way and i think is also one of
the things that makes me very good at
investing is
i'm not part of the crowd that everybody
you know listening to what everybody
else is doing
definitely pick up my own mind so so
where do you see yourself then i don't
know 10 20 years
man dead by corona in like half a
year
i don't know it's like no i mean where
do you go from here so if you're
i mean you have on one hand the
ambitions of of a finance of a finance
guy at the other hand
you want to travel the world and live
comfortably how do you see yourself
continuing to balance the two
do you go off and live in the amazonas
or go back to wall street
so it's a very good question what you
ask and i think from
my own perspective is i go with my
intuition i i don't have
my my longest plan is around three
months
i go to a country you know i'm lucky
that i can afford
to kind of like live in most places that
i want to and i can afford to just
change my mind every day and move to a
new place once again i
want to repeat that you don't have to be
a multi-millionaire to do that it's just
you just you know you have to be
comfortable and
you mentioned if you have friends who do
that on you know thousands of dollars
yeah do you mean the vacation things
yeah
uh well that's right to live in these
places
oh yeah you know there's many like for
example in bali even if i want to i
cannot spend more than three thousand
dollars even if i insist i can't i can't
you know unless you're an idiot that
likes to buy bottles and show off
you know you can't spend that money you
know and it's
just like crazy like you living i just
live in colombia
you know panama bali and you know you go
with your intuition when your intuition
if you
my intuition will tell me okay this now
it's time to live here for the next 10
years i will do that
if my intuition tells me it's time to
leave after three months i will leave
i think your intuition is your sm
the smartest person you should listen to
you know it's your higher self talking
to you
is that is does it get lonely sometimes
um it does i won't lie it does get
lonely
and the but the problem is then it gets
lonely and then i go back to my
you know my base which where i have a
lot of friends if it's berlin if it's
new york if it's tel aviv
yeah and the monotony just kills me so
i prefer to be lonely then live a
monotonous life you know but but the
thing is like
now the world is changing and there's
this thing phenomena called digital
nomads
yeah there's a lot of people like me
that you know
across the world you know they're kind
of like
work online and etc so it's it's really
a lot of other people are doing it so
you find a community of people that
understand you
and they're in the same situation yeah i
actually i know people who are
starting who are working on building
these communal living spots in like
thailand and valley and all these areas
four digital nomads
that are with with wi-fi and electricity
and everything
but they're also very you know out in
the middle of nowhere
selena i don't know if you heard about
that group selena which is a couple of
group of israelis that i met in panama
and they started from one apartment to
one stuff like that and now
they raised money on a base of like 1.6
billion dollars so you know
yes definitely crazy omar this was
fascinating but before we go i have to
put you on the spot
one last time and i'd love to know
three words that you would describe
yourself as and i'm especially curious
to hear
your response to this open-minded
and if you're open mind you have to go
to berlin love the good life and if you
love the good life
you have to go to bali and
i don't know excite i think
fearless and i think if if all of you
whoever does meditation higher level
meditation and stuff like that
it's not like a fearless it's a fearless
point of view that you understand that
death is just another beginning
so there's really nothing to worry about
so do what you want to do meditation
and then how often do you do it
meditation
every day wow for how long
around half an hour wow highly
recommended
i've been doing it for 10-15 minutes
through headspace i'm
still getting into it so i have remind
me i have a lot of good stuff to give
you
fantastic i've heard of vipassana a lot
of people have been telling me about
vipassana
i think you are going to be more
fascinated with obes which is out of
body experiences
but we can discuss this a lot we're
gonna have to talk about that after the
show
done oh man thank you hi michael thank
you so much was a pleasure
thank you brother
you